hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website calm today are going to be going
over the King's game at the Kline line
specifically the classical defense the
King's gambit is one of my favorite
openings I prefer the accepted lines but
you can't always force your opponent to
accept your gambits so I see a slew of
different variations as far as how
people attack the King's gambit one
variation I see every now and then is
the classical defense oh I thought I'd
make an in-depth video over the
classical defense some of the things
they're trying to do and then what
White's should do and how they should
attack it specifically those players
that are playing the King's gambit
because that's usually more of an
aggressive player so that's what this
video is going to be about the King's
gambit if you're not too familiar with E
4 E 5 and then pawn to f4 trying to give
up this pawn looking for the pawn to
take here on f4 so that y can get a
counter-attack that counter-attack is
going to be trying to control the center
of the board open up the semi open file
on the F file to try to reign down if Y
it decides to castle on the Kings side
with his rook right here but the
classical defense is very simple and
it's Bishop here to c5 developing one of
the minor pieces for black but it really
weighs on White's King son right away it
stops white from castling on the King
side many players when they see this
they just get really frustrated
sometimes you may see the knight coming
here to c3 getting ready to come to a
four just so it can kind of you know
move this Bishop here along this long
diagonal because they really don't want
to have to worry about this Bishop
keeping them from castling on the King
side again so many players just see some
of these defenses and they just don't
know how to react after this video
hopefully you'll know exactly how to
play against this classical defense now
what we're going to do is continue the
same as we would if we were having this
pawn take here on f4 and that is the
Knights going to come here to f3 again
it's attacking the center of the board
it's getting another minor piece
involved into the action but it first
thing it really stops us from a trap
that I see every now and then from after
this Bishop coming to c5 some players
will play pawn
seventy-five this is a critical mistake
the Queen can now come down to H for
threatening the pawn has to come here
because you know if the King comes is
just going to be checkmate right away so
after the pawn comes to a g3 and the
Queen comes up here then it doesn't
really matter how white blocks it but
the Queen is going to come to h1 and
gobble up material so it's very
important for white right away to stop
this Queen coming here to h4 what better
way to do that than to play the normal
move that white does in the King's
gambit accepted lines and that's Knight
coming here to f3 so from this setup
right here black has a lot of different
options so we're going to go over as
many variations that I think that you
need to be prepared for white but we're
also going to talk about what black
should do what black shouldn't do and
then hopefully by the end of it you'll
have enough knowledge to know based on
your playing style how you should
proceed as wife so in this particular
case black has again many ways that he
can play the worst option I think is for
just a pawn to take here on f4 excepting
the gambit just to move later because
this really allows white to control the
game he can play pawn here to d4 it's
going to force the bishop to move
doesn't really matter where it moves the
next move is going to be for this bishop
to take care on f4 even if he tries to
come back here to d6 defending this
after the pawn moves after the bishop
takes on f4 this is going to be a very
very dominant game for white he's
controlling the turn of the board with
both his D and E pawns he has you know
his dark square Bishop out involved
which sometimes it's very hard for white
to do that he's easily going to be
castling on either side of the board so
really really going to be a strong game
for white but again there's a lot of
options that black has one of the most
common options that you'll see is pawn
here to d6 now Bobby Fischer when he
refuted the Kings gambit wrote a whole
article about it he accepted the Kings
gambit and then he played his pawn to d6
it's kind of a waiting move it does
allow in this particular case more of a
support on this 'if I've it also allows
for this LightSquared bishop to come out
play in this particular game but it's
very nice defense for black he does have
his dark square bishop outside of the
pawn chain so we can kind of lock it
right here and so this is where we're
going to focus a lot of our time because
this is the most common move that you'll
from black now from here there's many
ways that Y can continue but we're going
to focus on one because I think it's the
best I think it's the easiest to learn
and it gives white the most options to
win the game and that is pawn here to c3
it's a move I don't see very often but
it's very very important in this
particular opening now again we still
want the same thing as before we really
want black to play pawn takes on f4 it's
going to be the same the palm pushes
forward here to d4 and then the bishops
going to take here on f4 this is going
to be critical for white to go on and
win but again blacks probably not going
to do that he does have a lot of other
options right here one option that you
may see is the knight coming here to f6
seems pretty common getting ready to
castle on the King side developing more
of his minor pieces from here White's
going to continue and just push forward
with pawn here to d4 pawn can no longer
take here on f4 because the bishops
going to fall so that's definitely gonna
be a bad move so one thing you may see
is just the pawn ticking here on d4 the
pawn is just going to recapture the
black Bishop is going to retreat it
could come back here to b6 not super
common more than likely you may see the
bishop coming here to b4 check very
important now not to play knight here to
c3 because of knight here to e4 this is
just going to be very very dangerous as
white can no longer take and he has to
defender or two attackers here on c3
much better to go ahead and just defend
with bishop here on d2 if he decides to
go ahead and take that's going to be
completely fine the knight can take and
now it's protecting this this pawn here
on e4 if instead the bishop doesn't take
you might see something pawn here to a5
that's going to be fine the white canal
pawn can push forward to e5 threatening
you know you could see an exchange right
here and then this is going to be very
good for white as we kind of look at it
so you could even see now the bishop
take and that the knight take right here
the knight has to move bishop can get
involved into the game c4 this is
definitely going to be good for white as
he controls the center of the board if
we kind of look at how we know a side is
doing well this but to your case if both
are equal White has more pieces
developed and he has both of his pawns
here firmly in the stern of the board
this is definitely going to be good for
white another thing that you may see
instead of the pawn taking here on d4
the bishop could just come back here to
b6 a nice safe area still trying to
control this long diagonal right here
why can now take with this pawn here on
e5 again this pawn white really wanted
to give it up at the beginning of the
game so if he can go ahead and start
taking material get this you know F file
semi opens we can start doing some
damage that's going to be completely
fine with him few options from black
right now he could take with his pawn if
you wanted to then after the exchange
right here you know White has a pretty
good game again he's controlling the
center of the board he's no longer
threatened as far as not being able to
castle on the King side so this is going
to be completely fine for him instead of
the pawn taking back something you could
so you could be a little bit tricky you
could see the knight coming down and
taking on e4
now the Bishop's going to come here to
d3 getting ready to castle on the King
side also getting a LightSquared bishop
involved into the game attacking the
knight the Knights going to have to go
somewhere doesn't have too many great
moves you can't move back here to g5
because there's two attackers the bishop
and also this knight right here you may
see pawn here to d5 trying to protect it
right here which makes a lot of sense
now Knight here - D - threatening right
here it's going to be completely fine
you know if this knight takes here on D
- Bishop can take again if we look at it
White has way more pieces developed in
the game next move he can castle on the
King side he's dominating the sin of the
board way ahead in this game white
should definitely do very very fine
could in this particular case try
something a little cute you could see
the pawn coming here to f5 again there's
a move on Passats
if the next move looks kind of weird to
you you can you can look it up but the
pawn can take here on f6 few ways for
black to take the best move is probably
Knight to f6 to go ahead and take like
that and then after Queen to e2 blacks
force to respond and then white can
castle on the King side more than likely
it's going to be a mistake if he takes
with his Queen right here would be an
even bigger mistake if he took with his
pawn just because he's just he has an
isolated pawn right here
King sides completely just broken up
right here but even if he takes with his
queen right here after the night takes
and the pawn takes and the bishop
recaptures on e4y it's just really
really far ahead in this with to your
game he's again going to be looking to
castle on the Kings side and then launch
an attack on black another move you may
see from black is a pretty aggressive
counter-attack and it's pawn to f5 now
if your opponent hasn't played the
classical defense very often usually we
won't see pawn to f5 just because
there's a lot of different tricky ways
this can go and you probably don't want
to play something like this but again if
someone's playing the classical defense
more than likely they're pretty familiar
with this type of variation so I've seen
it quite often so there's about three
ways that you can attack this I'm going
to kind of go over some of the reasons
you should shouldn't you can kind of
side what you think is best one option
that you have is pawn taking on f5 and
again even if you run this particular
case through a chess engine it may tell
you that it's not too bad for white I'm
going to tell you that it's really
difficult for white to play in this
particular case black can now take with
this Bishop here on f5 it is a very
active game a lot of what White's trying
to do in the King's gambit attack you
really lose after the bishop takes here
on f5 and black now controls the center
of the board you can get some counter
play Black's not going to control both
of this D and E pawn in the center of
the board for very long you can always
take with your pawn if you wanted to
right here but it is now going to be
more difficult to castle it's going to
be more difficult to get more counter
play black now has a very active
position he can get his queen involved
you can play Knight to c6 castle on the
Queen set if you wanted to or can also
castle on the King side and they get is
very active rook here on the F file
which is soon to be a fully open F file
another option that white has instead of
taking right here is he could take with
this pawn here on e5 this just gets
completely chaotic because after that
pawn takes and you know the D pawn takes
here on e4 then kind of what his white
dude does white retreat his knight does
he play pawn here to f4 and then both
sides decided to go ahead and exchange
pieces off the board you can get pretty
chaotic I think one of the easier way
to play for white instead of worrying
about this pawn here on f4 our on f5 is
sticking with a game plan that white
already has he has this pawn here on c3
reason for that is to play pawn here to
d4 to counter-attack control the center
of the board and to make way if he wants
to castle on the King side he wants to
kind of block this bishop off from
really doing anything now there's a few
ways that white may encounter black to
respond to this one way would be just
the pawn taking here on e4 right here
very very common from here White has a
pretty creative way of responding
instead of taking with the bishop and
then losing his knight right here he can
actually take with his night here on e5
he welcomes the opportunity to have his
knight being taken back here on e5
because now after Queen to h5 blacks in
a world of hurt he can't play pawn here
to g6 because he's gonna lose his rook
here on h8 we kind of look at it what is
black do if he plays the King here to d7
we could just have the pawn take here on
e5 that's not going to be great for
black again he's still being attacked
and he's under a lot of pressure from
White's if he comes over here and just
you know quick King here to e7 can be
pretty bad the Queen can now just come
here to e5 very active position the
bishop can fall pretty soon right here
if he comes back here to let's say King
to f8 we can now have the bishop come
here to c4 centralizing developing
another minor piece controlling the
center but also threatening another
mates and one here on f7 the bishop
still under attack this is going to be
very very good for whites if we come
back and look at what other moves black
and do we already talked about if black
takes here on e4 another option is for
the pawn to come here to d4
we already know that if the pawn takes
here the bishop is going to fall we're
not going to see that but we could see
the pawn take here on a d4 now after the
pawn takes the bishop is probably going
to come here to b4 we're not super
worried if the bishop comes back here to
b6 but if it does come here to B for
checking we want to make sure that we
play bishop here to d2 again we don't
want to play this knight here to c3
and have to worry about pawn here to e4
because we can't move our knife because
it's being pinned down we want to play
this Bishop here to d2 now if the pawn
takes here on e4 we're not too worried
we can just take this Bishop if it takes
right here
White has an incredibly good game he has
more developed pieces he is both his
Bishop payer and since it's an open game
White's going to have a lot of ways to
attack while black
none of his pieces are developed and so
he's going to be scrambling trying to
have some counter play now the bishop
does come back here and take here on
Bishop to d2 again that's going to come
here to the two now protecting this pawn
here on e4 another thing that you could
see potentially instead of the pawns
taking either way is just a bishop
coming back here to b6 again fairly
straight forward as far as you know not
really trying to attack any way from
here white can just continue with pawn
taking here on d5 or a 5 if the pawn now
comes here to e4 again if we step back
just a second the pawn here to f5 taking
that's just going to be difficult to
play again so we don't want to have to
do that if we don't have to so instead
we can just play pawn taking here on e5
and now if the pawn takes ours here on
e4 we could play Knight here to g5 very
very nice move we're now threatening
this pawn here on e4 it can be very
difficult to kind of hold on to that
pawn here to f5 or d5 really allows us
to start to put more and more pressure
on this game from white so again this is
going to be very very good for white and
it all stems from after that c3 move and
then we have F 2 pawn to f5 we have
pawned pushing forward to d4 so we
talked a lot about in the classical
defense after this pawn here to d6 it is
the most common that you'll see but you
won't always see it another move that
you may see is Knight here to c6 getting
another minor piece developed in the
game from here it's going to be pawn
taking here
on e5 Black has a few options of how he
wants to respond sometimes you may see
the knight take here on e5 now it is
kind of crazy if you want to take you
don't have to take back right away you
could play the safe move a bishop here
to e2 the reason for that is if you do
take here on Knight to e5 more than
likely your opponent is kind of setting
this up and he's going to play Queen
here to h4 really only move that White
has is to play pawn here to g3 after the
Queen's going to come here to e4 then
after Queen to e2 the rook is going to
fall on h1 then the Knights going to
come here to g6 discovered check so
black has to deal with that there's no
matter how the response goes Knight here
to e7 sure doesn't really matter same
with Bishop coming here to e7 the
Knights now going to come to h8 so this
is a pretty chaotic way for this game to
go so it's kind of up to you once your
opponent plays that Knight taking on e5
if you want to go down the crazy trail
or if you want to just play it safe play
Bishop here to e2 and then later on you
can push forward with pawn here to d4 if
you want to and then castle on the King
side or how you want to respond the last
variation we're going to go over is
somewhat less common but I have seen it
before so we're going to go over it and
that's Knight here to f6 as you can
imagine this pawn that we're just going
to give up for free if we can now start
to take material and we're not too
worried about a queen coming here to h4
having any shenanigans we're just going
to take this pawn here on e5 now black
can respond and just take our pawn here
on e4 so we'll kind of go through what
this looks like as far as a continuation
the pawn is going to come here to d4
forcing this bishop away solidifying the
center of the board for white right here
the bishop can go a few places it's
probably not going to come here to b4
it's going to be pretty easy just a
block right here White has a long pawned
chain right here he's going to be
attacking on the King side it's pointing
towards the King side the move more
common would be Bishop here to e7 going
back here to FA
doesn't make a lot of sense because
black can no longer castle on the
kingside so that's why we're going to be
going over Bishop coming here to e7
now the bishops going to come here to d3
again we want to get this light square
bishop to attack develop it but also get
ready to castle on the King side because
that is one of the reasons why someone
plays the Kings gambit is to open up
this F file and then dominate it with
his rook here on f1 so from here how
does black respond he could play pawn
here to the d5 if he wanted to
controlling probably don't want to on
passant right here but you can
counter-attack with pawn here to see
file to c4 again from here white can
cast on the King side and continuous
plan black doesn't have as good of a
gain as white so I'm not usually too
worried about the knight coming here to
f6 right away so again this was a lot of
variations in the classical defense it's
a simple move on paper but there's a lot
to it so hopefully now if you play the
King's gambit and your opponent plays
the classical defense which is Bishop
here to c5 you now have a better idea of
how to attack it hopefully you guys
enjoy it and I'll see on the next video
thanks for watching